[Music]
hi
my name is brady forest i am the
co-founder of
ignite talks and a long now member
uh you know the long now is known for
giving
great or hosting great amazing talks
and ignite is kind of a sister
organization
uh that's been around since 2006 and
is experienced with having lots of short
talks and so back in 2015 we had our
first
ignite long now collaboration where we
had 12
members of the long now community get up
and do a five minute talk
and we've decided to replicate that here
today except
virtually because kovid
case you're not familiar with ignite
it's
a short form format and each of the
speakers you're about to see will get
five minutes to share their idea
talk about history to try to inspire you
they will each have 20 slides and they
will each
only have 15 seconds per slide so again
that's a total of five minutes
now we had over 80 applicants for
this set of talks we have 12 speakers
today
um there are ignites that happen around
the world so
feel free to apply to any of those for
uh to share your idea and hopefully
we'll do this again
sometime with the long now so now i'd
like to
welcome up our first speaker
mark pomelo he is most importantly for
this talk
a bay area native but he's also a
multiple time
founder and he is going to talk take us
on a walk
through chinatown take it away mark and
thank you for being here
thank you
think about san francisco in the late
60s and images like this might appear in
your head
the summer of love hippies timothy leary
the grateful dead and explosion of youth
culture
chinatown never makes that highlight
real and yet three miles due east from
hate street a transformation was
happening
centered around a pool hall founded by
american-born chinese gangsters
and a japanese-american gang member from
oakland they called it leeways
short for legitimate ways and the
mission was to find employment and
recreation for the youth of our
community
gangs like the raiders the immortals
abc's and fobs passed through played
pool and pinball
danced bought and sold drugs guns and
fireworks
smoked grass dropped acid fell in love
raised kids built community
and tried to change the world leeways
tried to do what had never been done
before
and now with society and politics so
polarized and divisive
chinatown and its wisdom and its lessons
so long hidden from view
should be shared so this is a love story
about chinatown its past and what that
pass could mean for its future
many of these photos by my friend jerry
jew have never been seen before
the negatives stashed away in shoe boxes
for nearly 60 years
thank you jerry for trusting me with
them
now this is not one of jerry's pictures
he's old but not that old these are
chinatown gangster circa 1892 when
chinatown was 90
men railroad laundry and factory workers
who couldn't vote own land or marry
outside their race
42 years later bruce lee born three
blocks away
managed to do all three before passing
in 73
eight years after the 1882 chinese
exclusion act
was finally repealed and a new wave of
chinese arrived in chinatown forming
their own gangs
like peter from the watching and the joe
louis boys
leeways was about transcending beef
happening on the streets
bands of chinese whites and blacks
filled portsmouth square with the sound
of rock and roll and motown songs like
you're still a young man suavecito and i
can't get next to you
this was a time when making out in park
cars in broad daylight was cool to
figure out who you are and what you
really wanted to be
in an america your ancestors ancestors
have always felt
a tenuous love for a land they embraced
but rarely kissed them
back while back in the mainland mao's
cultural revolution
annihilated thousand-year-old norms
while girlfriends of watching gangsters
fall into the center of a women's rights
movement
and america's own brand of revolution i
think of stories like my buddy
derek quan derek saw this picture of
himself
he said my father cq was a notorious
gangster and leeway's member
he passed in 98 and mom's not talking
but i do believe i was conceived
on top of that that pinball pinball
machine at leeways
sometimes cq would get high pour me into
the 58 chevy around midnight
rumble six blocks to the bottom of
lombard peel out burning rubber and
sliding no seat belt
up the wrong way of that one crooked
street laughing
and it was moments like this i knew he
was truly happy
asians have a long history of swimming
upstream against the current in america
going the wrong way up lombard a
rebellion defiance against a system that
for centuries
wanted asian hands for labor but not our
rights for equal treatment
listen the truth is san francisco
chinatown isn't even supposed to be here
after the 1906 earthquake city hall
tried to move chinatown to hunter's
point
chinatown found ways to stay
transforming into a tourist destination
and this pandemic means chinatown must
reinvent itself again
and i believe the spirit of leeways is
exactly what is needed
when the so-called model minority
experimented with marijuana and orange
sunshine
redefine traditional roles and dream
dreams bigger than any generation before
them
i think of 1969 in the movie easy rider
the desire it must have sparked
expansive boundless potential to venture
beyond chinatown's borders aspirations
so mind-blowingly different
than what their parents could imagine
while hollywood's mr yoshida in
breakfast and tiffany's
charlie chan cato the houseboy the
cooley stereotypes of asian men
shattered by bruce lee and jerry's
pictures
even in 2020 these dudes still look like
the badass as they were
and still are today think of all this
change and the speed of it
how discombobulating this must have felt
to their parents and grandparents
who wanted to leave revolution behind
not have their children to be part
of igniting a perilous new one leeways
eventually became radicalized
factionalized a red guard movement
drawing the eyes of the fbi and the
wrath of chinatown six companies
sfpd raids on leeways eventually closed
it down forever
there are lessons here too but i'm
telling you
things are bubbling in chinatown now
again under the surface
the old folks you pass on chinatown
streets may be the kids in jerry's
photos
now just older and wiser versions they
remember
they still all have a dream for
chinatown
to rise again thank you
thank you mark that was a really
amazing dedication to such an awesome
neighborhood in sf when was the last
time you were there
uh yesterday i go there uh
pretty much every day i'm part of the
united peace collaborative uh which
patrols the streets and i also do
tours in chinatown
great well thank you for sharing this
thank you very much for having me
and now we're going to talk about how
activism
brings a better future or at least a
different one
please welcome allison cooper thank you
i'm allison and i'm going to talk about
how we can change the world with
long-term thinking
i want to start with montreal in 2012.
every night for months and months we
marched endless crowds of students
filling the city's arteries every night
as the sun went down
and every single night after rinsing off
the tear gas
tired from running through the city i
went to sleep truly deeply feeling in my
bones that another world was possible
that this was something important and
unprecedented and unstoppable
and that tomorrow everything could be
different for me as a young american
student who grew up with the assumption
of going into debt for college
when i first heard that quebec students
would go on strike to fight less than 2
000 canadian dollars and propose tuition
hikes
and further that organizers were
demanding that higher education be
tuition free
i'll admit at first i was shocked at the
absurdity and the grandiosity of that
idea
but the unions leading these protests
took a longer view forward imaginations
fueled by the potential found in a
longer view back
support for free education view grew
popular discussed in the mainstream
i'd only joined in once the movement was
underway without realizing it had
actually been in the works for much
longer
through a history of previous waves and
coalition building that had only just
come to a head
researching quebec student movement
history i learned that in the 60s
more conservative students commonly
called for a tuition freeze with
centrists demanding free tuition
while the progressive call at the time
was for students to be salaried
these expansions of what's possible
reminded me of a recent seminar about
long-term thinking with dr loni j
avi brooks describing how queer
afrofuturisms can serve to widen our
aperture for the future
instead of viewing the possibilities the
future holds through a narrow straw
limited in our imagination with a wider
view we see how much more could be
possible
this insight into the normalization of
free higher education 50 years ago
and again in 2012 helped me see how
limited my thinking had been
it took me much longer to catch up to
those earlier change makers with wider
views when i saw only my more narrow
cone of possible futures
a wider aperture could even drive
accelerated change and access to these
preferable futures
so what other possible features could we
be missing out on with our traditional
narrow views
there are bigger visions better possible
worlds that we miss out on without this
how can we get there with this to this
viewpoint where more is possible
the abolition movement today is a
powerful example of widening our
collective
possible futures window abolishing the
police and prison industrial complex is
shocking to many today
but to propose it to consider it and to
demand it inherently widens the realm of
what's possible for the benefit of all
of us
angela davis and mariam cabba's insights
they of course have led amazing work
here and i've learned so much from it
their insights on building systems for
community safety and harm reduction with
the potential to grow until they might
make traditional policing obsolete
show that we can build pockets of the
future that we want today functioning
alongside
and within present systems alternatives
to policing have been being explored and
built by black activist leaders for well
before many white activists like me
became aware of the idea at all like the
black panthers work to establish free
food systems and other community
programs
black organizers have long set some of
the best examples for this kind of world
building as a futurist
activist tactic in this way sometimes
the future already actually exists
recognizing that the present might be
wider and more diverse than we thought
also widens our lens into the future
and identifying these preferable
features in the world today helps us
reset that timeline
another challenge where we need to
incorporate these long view tactics is
climate change
this is a still from alexandria
ocasio-cortez's film project a message
from the future which envisions a
near-term future scenario
to help us imagine what the ambitious
green new deal could do
you can't be what you can't see the
green new deal and also the rewiring
america work as well
pushes our apertures by proposing
alternative visions for our future
with these frameworks we're armed with
detailed plans to ground further
imaginations
just painting the picture of what's
possible helps us widen our apertures
too
but i guess we could also do nothing
we've seen in california recently the
first hand effects that this has
made all too real and i think it's clear
that this is less preferable but still a
possible future
but this is business as usual the path
of least resistance other futures are
urgently needed to be imagined
to prevent that from happening together
these imagine expanded views give us new
ideas for futures to work toward
they power the ability to normalize
moonshot ideas into the mainstream
and provide a platform for expanding
experiments today as future solutions
they remind us that for any movement we
need to look back further to understand
its deeper vision and further ahead to
see its true potential
i'm hoping that these stories can serve
as a reminder that long-term thinking in
itself can change the world
and even help us feel tomorrow and that
there are many different ways to engage
with these possibilities
i mean it can all benefit you from more
voices being brought into the
conversation
so at its core any work to identify
imagine or build better worlds can
change the present
looking further into what's possible
allows us to see this wider range
illuminating possible better
alternatives that could be filtered out
as unrealistic in a shorter view
or preventing us from being distracted
by incremental ideas
so another world is possible tomorrow it
could all be different
i carry that feeling with me from
montreal that physical sense of shouting
in the streets giving me a real
tangible sense of what's next through
world building today and long-term
thinking forward and back
we have so many possibilities to move
toward please be in touch if you'd like
to talk more about this
thank you and i can't wait to build new
worlds with you
thank you allison what is the world
you're trying to build right now
the one that's not on fire definitely
yeah
yeah i think that there's so much that's
already being done that i just have a
lot more reading to do
yeah well thank you very much for uh
sharing this
and hopefully we'll see you again soon
now our next speaker uh previously at
the new york times
now at google and is going to share some
insights from his most recent trip to
italy
thanks well about eight months ago
tomorrow i was in siena italy looking at
this painting in this room
that was the same day that italy went
into its quarantine just in the north
and the way those two are connected to
me is something i want to talk about
today inside the context of long wave
cultural effects
first though you gotta see sienna this
is the first
landscape painting since the roman
empire it's also
the first or the last painting since the
black before the black death
but sienna has so much more going on
than that in 1260 sienna was a republic
that's the same time this pulpit was
carved reviving roman sculptural
tradition
and in 1310 it wrote the first
vernacular constitution
about the same time this 15 by 16 foot
altarpiece was developed
so what is going on that makes sienna
such a big deal it's actually
globalization from the mongols
who connect europe and asia and have
these trade routes and siena goes in for
luxury goods and banking you actually
see some silks
and some tartar writing there behind the
virgin and the altarpiece
but it's not like everything's all
sweetness and light in the world there's
still mercenary warfare and all kinds of
mayhem
and around siena and rebellion in siena
so this group of rulers these elites
called the nine
decided they better get some allegory
going on and they hire a painter and he
comes up with a plan
and if you script strip away the angels
a lot of it's kind of familiar
wisdom from heaven dispenses justice the
people agree there's a wise ruler the
nine
and he provides peace peace actually
sleeps on armor in that picture
what happens if there is no justice well
stop me if this seems familiar
there's tyranny it's a narcissist he's
full of selfishness
he's surrounded by these people who just
want to sow discord and violence
and make life hell for everyone it's
terrible to live there
and if you're a 14th century christian
it's worse than that
you're not just in this lonely
environment where it's every man for
himself
the only way you can live in a world
like this is to sin which means you're
going to go to hell forever that sounds
like a really bad deal
what happens if there is justice in the
world well it turns out people work
together under justice there's community
and more than that the seven arts are
revived what god designed for us to work
and find meaning in the world so we can
ascend
even those theatrical dancers are
chasing away the worms of melancholy you
can see them there on the gown
well good mission statement the nine but
plague
comes in 1346 races across europe kills
like the dickens sometimes in just a day
wipes out 30 percent of the population
sometimes worse in places than others
take for example sienna
which lost 50 to 70 of its population in
just a couple of years
in fact it didn't recover its population
until about 1950
which is one reason it's such a great
place to visit today
but then let's open the lens a little
wider because the plague doesn't end in
five years
the plague actually goes for about 350
years flaring up every generation or so
people are arising and you know hearing
about these terrible deaths somewhere
near them
and this is a long wave effect that
changes the consciousness in europe
you start to see it very soon after
where there's an isolation
asia is a distant place we're not in
contact with anymore
we don't really know what's going on
there's an uncertainty and out of this
we create this new world of
individuals and it's not all bad because
in the renaissance
we start celebrating great individual
artists
and we um thinkers as diverse as martin
luther and machiavelli
right against each other 150 years later
are talking about the individual and
god or the individual who's on his own
and how that creates the state
and they all have plague stories dig
deep everybody's got one
shakespeare's birthplace lost 20 of his
population when he was a baby
he goes on to event new emotional
experiences galileo relocates
rock and newton's on a plague break when
he comes up with gravity
optics and calculus modernity so there i
am
eight months ago tomorrow having my
dinner and thinking about how all this
came together
art and religion and politics and just a
couple days later
something kind of rhymes in history
that's right
covid now covet is not the black death
it's not lethal like that
but i posit the covet is happening
during a new long wave what i call the
age of hyper awareness
where we have social networks and
science and sensors
and massive computation cloud computing
including my boss insert
virtual disclaimer here we virtualized
ourselves inside this pandemic with
fascinating and great results
but if we really have hyper awareness
maybe we can also be aware of history
and how we will change our consciousness
and be mindful of that
and remember that without peace and
justice tyranny and selfishness rule
and everyone's disconnected like say if
you politicize a disease and we all
start fighting with each other
but let's remember the other wall and
how some of the secret to life is to
find
meaning and work in each other to find
each other essential
let's bake that into this new long wave
of hyper awareness
and hope for the best thank you so much
thank you clinton and what is the one
takeaway you want everyone to
to walk away from this talk with
rhymes in beautiful ways we can learn
from that
all right thank you very much for uh
being here today
i'm going to welcome our next speaker
now
please welcome asmr merrick she is
as the title says gonna be sharing the
future of storytelling
take it away thank you
i'm a filmmaker writer film professor
and founder of kinovat.com
an online digital film studio i'm here
to talk about the future of storytelling
my name is asmara i love my name as a
child
because it was listed in the thick
dictionary we had
it was there because it is a city and
happened to be in bold at the top as a
search heading
that made me feel important there's a
story about my name that comes from
tugrenia
it means asmara which means the
four are united the story goes that the
male leaders of the four villages were
fighting
the women came together and calmed
tensions by creating the capital city of
asmara
they united the four i am named after
that city which lies high in the
mountains of east africa
i'll share with you my thoughts about
storytelling first about storytellers
then about technology and finally the
media industry
my thoughts about the future
paradoxically are grounded in the past
and the natural world
there are four directions on the compass
and four elements in nature
earth symbolizes stability water our
subconscious air the mind and fire
action and change a hopi prophecy
symbolized by this medicine wheel says
that
long ago the great spirit gathered the
peoples of this earth together and said
i'm going to send you to four directions
and change you to four colors
i'll give you special teachings to the
red people i give guardianship over the
earth
to the black people over water to the
yellow people
guardianship over air and the white
people guardianship over fire
when you come back together you will
share these so that you can live and
have peace on earth and a great
civilization will come about
if you do not share not only will human
beings have a hard time but almost the
earth itself
will die the animated series avatar
depicts a version of this tale a world
that is out of balance with the fire
nation having too much power
so my first point about the future of
storytelling
is that it has to be inclusive not as a
favor
or out of pity to anyone left out but as
an urgent necessity to create a
comprehensive global
knowledge system for example i'm in
california right now and concerned i
might miss this talk because my power
could be cut off to avoid another
massive
fire years ago settlers in this area
banned native american tribes from
performing controlled burns which
cleaned forests thus preventing
large-scale wildfires
this practice took thousands of years to
develop it is part of our overlooked
knowledge system and we need it now
next i would like to speak with you
about technology which some fear is
burning out of control and
nature of storytelling the term ludite
refers to someone who opposes
technological advancements the word
comes from a band of english workers who
destroyed machinery especially textile
mills
because they feared the machines would
take their jobs now we know that
technology usually creates new jobs just
different kinds of them
today we feel robots taking over and
humans becoming surplus
we are anxious that social media is a
nexus of misinformation
and distortion bringing the downfall of
not only democracy but
even human decency in the film the red
desert
directed by antonioni the main character
anxiously wanders around barren
landscapes haunted by the loud sound of
machinery painted in audacious colors
film critics said it showed the problems
of industry but antonioni said
you don't quite understand the problem
is not the machines
the problem is the humans who have not
yet adapted
we can't solve global problems with
national structures and we need
technology to unite the global community
we don't need to fear an upgrade of tech
as much as we need to upgrade ourselves
we must evolve spiritually emotionally
and psychologically to make use of new
and emerging technological tools to
better ourselves and society and to
share our local stories internationally
as for the industry the business of
storytelling particularly finance is
changing
through blockchain technology film
productions have followed the same
globalization path of other industries
going abroad for tax incentives
so that where the story takes place has
little or no relation to where it is
filmed or whose story it is
this has to change we need local hubs of
storytelling
we need to develop global financial
structures that create equitable pay for
everyone in the industry we need to
respect the story itself the author
and the people who live these stories to
tell stories with integrity
empathy and compassion to think that
well maybe the indians aren't the bad
guys fighting to protect the land for
themselves
maybe they are fighting to protect it
for everybody including you
so to summarize the future of
storytelling is inclusive
it is high tech it is empathetic it
operates on a higher spiritual
psychological
and emotional plane than where we are
now it is time to unite the four
directions the four corners and the four
peoples of the earth
the four are united
i recently learned that asmara also
means love in malay from sanskrit
so let's unite the four and let's do it
with love thank you
thank you asmara and one of the things i
like about your talk
is that it is a talk about storytelling
and packed as an example of how to do
an amazing story so what how did you
select your opening gambit that pulls us
all in
uh with my name or you mean the hopi
prophecy
uh your name i guess it just came
intuitively actually and
i've been fascinated by that hopi story
and i actually never
realized this link that the four are
united is also the hopi story and that
it happened in eritrea which is where my
father was born
so that was a new discovery for me that
inspired me to share
well thank you very much for giving the
talk today and being with us thank you
so much
now our next speaker
is an artist but her medium is very
different
from most artists anyway please welcome
catherine chalmers thank you
my multimedia american cockroach project
which includes photography five short
films
drawing and sculpture was a 10-year
investigation into our adversarial
relationship with nature yes i raised
cockroaches for 10 years
because i could think of few animals
more hated than the roach
yet for me it was a conduit to the
negative and often violent tendencies
we have towards the animal world
para planeta americana the most common
domestic roach species
is no longer found in the wild it has
moved in
with us i documented the roach's life
eating drinking sex birth molting
in its now native habitat our home
as with all my projects i work with the
animals natural behavior
they are my collaborators i watch
respond experiment and adjust
through this back and forth process my
artwork takes shape
how do you work with the cockroach how
do you navigate the same space
without mutual terror and chaos
you think we hate them they are wildly
afraid of us
it's possible to frighten a roach to
death
10 minutes in the state of panic any can
die
of the equivalent of a roach heart
attack
did early homo sapiens find the
cockroach as detestable as we do now
certainly they had more dangerous
animals to fear
i think our hatred of the roach has
grown as we increasingly wall ourselves
off from the natural world
trespassers will be prosecuted
what are the aesthetics of our empathy
towards animals
would we like the cockroach better if it
had spots like a ladybug
or was fuzzy like a bumblebee or was
dawned with colorful feathers
like a bird of paradise people seem to
prefer
animals that are soft and furry as
opposed to hard and shiny
animals with big eyes as opposed to thin
antennae
but what do these qualities have to do
with the animal's importance to the
ecosystem
it points to the subjectivity perhaps
arbitrariness
of how we think about animals in general
yet these aesthetic preferences have
real consequences
all cultures have systems for
classifying and organizing
the natural world and such rankings are
rarely neutral or
objective these taxonomies determine
our emotional response towards different
species
and even entire classes of creatures
they also underlie our many
environmental policies
my cockroaches were disguised as insects
in a garden
looking pretty pollinating flowers
the idealized vision of nature
but most insects are predators savagely
ripping apart fellow insects
or in the case of the cockroach
recycling waste and debris
humans have a bias against scavengers
and that the american cockroach can
successfully scavenge off of us
further further fuels our hatred of them
and what we don't like we tend to kill
though not usually by hanging a gas
chamber
burning at the stake or electric chair
death ties us to the roach in a unique
way
we kill them they survive we kill
ourselves
they survive my executions were enacted
with already dead bugs
this series is not about the suffering
humans have endured at the hands of
humans
but what other species have endured
because of us
it's easy to keep abuse on creatures
whose lives are alien
and whose biology and behaviors seem
bizarre
and decidedly non-mammalian yet without
insects the terrestrial ecosystem would
crash in a matter of months
and how do we repay them for supporting
us
by hating them the cockroach is
emblematic of the questions we face
as we struggle to decipher our
relationship to the animal world in
general
what do we love what do we kill what do
we save and what goes extinct
my artistic career has been focused on
one central issue
how to confront and challenge our
human-centric point of view
we have been drawing lines in the sand
forever maybe now at the dawn of the
anthropocene
is a good time to reconsider those
divisions and what lives
on the other side thank you
thank you catherine and uh
what what is your art looking like now
in kobit
um i'm uh working uh with um the bark
beetle and fire two systems that are out
of balance in the
forest of the american west um so
i am actually further removed from kovid
because i'm out in the
uh in the forest in idaho usually
all right well thank you very much for
being with us here today
thank you now
our next speaker is gonna
share why
we uh should care about the oceans
oh wait no sorry we had like a small
a small mistake we're having some back
end difficulties
our next speaker is going to talk about
concrete
please welcome jason hello everybody
over 10 000 years ago humans began to
live in settled societies
and ever since then we've needed to
build structures
to house ourselves to store our goods
to honor the gods
earth in construction is fairly easy but
uh not very strong
wood is better but it tends to catch
fire
brick and stone are stronger still and
they're fireproof
but how do we build with them we can't
just stack them up we need to stick them
together
we need some sort of rock glue an
adhesive that's as strong as stone
itself
or long as i'm dreaming why not uh a
liquid rock that we could just pour
into molds and make in any shape we
wanted
well this futuristic sci-fi technology
actually exists today in fact it's been
around for millennia
it's called cement you probably think
cement is boring
i am here to convince you that it is
pure magic
how does it work well uh oh
it is uh actually one of the uh oldest
crafts cement is
older than uh pottery older than metal
working
probably even older than agriculture
cement floors were found at this
agricultural site in turkey gobekli tepe
from 9 600 bc
cement begins with limestone a
sedimentary rock formed from crushed
seashells
so the main ingredient in limestone is
calcium carbonate when you burn it
it gives off co2 and leaves behind
carbon
uh calcium oxide calcium oxide is a
caustic powder if you touch it it will
burn you
if you pour water into it it gives off
heat in an exothermic reaction in fact
enough to boil the water
the result of leaving behind the water
in the
calcium oxide is called slate lime or
hydrated lime
and if you pour that into a mold and let
it open to the air for a little while it
will absorb co2 from the air
and set as hard as stone the lime cycle
is complete the powder has turned back
into rock now a pure lime cement like
this
isn't very strong but if you add sand it
makes a mortar that you can
use to stick bricks together if you also
add pebbles and gravel
you get concrete which can be poured
into a mold
but we can make an even better cement
the ancient romans discovered that if
you
add volcanic ash to the lime you get a
cement that will set
even underwater very useful for making
harbors
uh this cement uses a different
chemistry by the way which we don't
fully understand today the romans were
masters of concrete they used it to
build the aqueducts
the coliseum the pantheon and of course
all these structures stood for two
thousand years they're still around
today
uh in the 1700s the eddie stone
lighthouse was rebuilt by john smeaton
a father of civil engineering using a
variation on the roman formula
it stood for over a hundred years and
was retired only
when the rock underneath it began to
erode
but we can make an even better cement if
you get your kiln hot enough when you're
firing the lime and silica
the result will form very hard nodules
called clinker
these are very hard to grind so they
were originally discarded as a waste
product
but if you do grind them you the
resulting powder is a cement that is
stronger than any other formula
it's called portland cement and it's
still the main type in use today uh ever
since it was invented in the 1800s
now all of these cements have a drawback
they have a lot of compressive strength
but they don't have a lot of tensile
strength
this is why the romans built with mostly
domes and arches
the round shape of the arch directs
forces into compression
along the arch the medieval builders did
a similar thing
they used the pointed gothic arch which
can stretch even higher than the round
roman ones
to prop up the high walls of their
cathedrals they used the flying buttress
all this making up for the deficiencies
of the concrete
but today we can do even better with
modern technology we can combine
uh concrete with another material that
has high tensile strength namely steel
the combination of the two is called
reinforced concrete and those
reinforcing bars are called naturally
enough
rebar there is a drawback
uh reinforced concrete does not last
nearly as long
the steel inside it eventually rusts no
matter how well you seal it away giving
it a lifetime of only about 50 to 100
years
uh compare this of course to the 2000
years of the roman concrete
but it's a trade-off with reinforced
concrete we can build structures
unlike anything the romans could build
such as the cantilever decks of falling
water
or the elegant half shell of the sydney
opera house
that is cement we crush and burn rock
extract its powdered essence and then
reconstitute it later
in any shape we choose like coffee or
instant pancake mix
it is instant stone just add water
thanks everybody i'm jason crawford
hey thank you for being here jason what
inspired you to talk about concrete
what structure made you want to dive in
uh i researched concrete because it is
one of the most important building
materials and i just found it to be this
thing that you know we would consider it
absolutely futuristic if it didn't
already exist
you know liquid rock that you can just
pour into a mold and it's uh and it's
you know essential for civilization
all right thank you very much for being
with us today
all right denise i think i think of all
of our speakers i've known you longest
you are an open source maven and
unsurprisingly you are here to talk
about
open source in a time of covid so thank
you both for your work and for sharing
your thoughts
thanks yes i am although that my title
is not exactly what i'm talking about
so about three years ago i moved to
ireland
i did this because of what was happening
in my life so as brady said i have spent
pretty much a lifetime now working on
open source and
some very important projects this is
where my office is now
it's as you can see a resort town not a
normal place for a tech office
and i went to work for this company at
least in part because
it was here and the ceo wanted to stay
where he was born
but through no fault of our own we ended
up writing the most popular covid
tracing app contact tracing app in the
world
and so this presentation is about how
you can't
ultimately change what happens to you
life just happens and
you have to go with what you know um
i've had wanderlust my whole life this
is morocco i lived in morocco for two
years while i was in the peace corps
right out of college
i lived a lot of places and a lot of
really pretty places that weren't
america
and um at some point i realized that you
could
travel full-time if you just got
interested in open source
and there are a few of us some of us in
the audience now that spent about 10
years
traveling full-time to make open source
real by
evangelizing it around the world and it
was really fun but the truth is my
houseplants looked like this the whole
time
i was so often gone and not home it was
kind of silly even to have a home
and i decided and maybe this was wrong
that i could change my
life by moving elsewhere um and
maybe finding a little more peace
realizing that
you know software isn't always as
important as we think it is
it's not world peace it's certainly not
super important to humanity most of the
time
so as i said before i moved to beautiful
ireland and it was
peaceful and i loved it so much for
two and a half years it was exactly what
i was looking for
although i was still traveling too much
and then of course we had
um you know the pandemic
and um boy it stopped everything in fact
ireland just today
it's decided they're stopping again
because they need to flatten their curve
again they don't have enough hospital
resources
so they have to stay on top of that
flattening
so you know we wanted to work on the
contact tracing app because we wanted to
help people get back to something like a
normal life
and not have to stay far away from each
other with fear and
you know i i'm not opposed to masks i
think they're great um but
we need ways for people to feel safe and
moreover when we wrote our app we wrote
it privacy first like
like i have never done before it's a
very small data set it doesn't know who
you are or where you are
but it's still able to help you protect
yourself and your family which is
amazing to me
we added a lot of features that the
european union didn't want us to add
like symptom trackers they wanted that
to be a separate app but we thought
if we don't put it all in one app how
are we going to get people to use all
these different bits
and this turned out to be a really
useful feature this one was even more
useful
it's information about where more cases
are so that you can make choices about
where to spend your summer
and a lot of people use this i mean we
have the best penetration of any
any contact tracer in the world almost
40 percent of our population
part of why that happened was because we
used open source
we open sourced the code base so that
privacy advocates could
look at it before we tried to get people
to use it and they became our biggest
advocates and that's why we have such a
big install base
then after we released it and got such a
great response we started worrying about
our neighbor to the north
northern ireland of course those six
counties are behind a border
that almost 30 000 people um cross over
every day and the uk was taking a
different tack
so we asked them if they would use our
app and they said yes
and in fact most of the uk
is is using our app now just not the uk
itself or
what we think of as as britain but
scotland gibraltar the isle of jersey
northern ireland and then we were able
to get people to use it in the us as
well so right now new york new jersey
uh pennsylvania and delaware are all
using this app that was crafted in
ireland
and that is a huge change for ireland to
have influence like that
in the world the biggest thing that
happened was we got asked to give it to
the linux foundation public health
initiative
and we did do that it's called covet
green and the reason that that's
important is people who are not going to
pay
our company to create a bespoke version
we'll still be able to use this simple
technology
to combat something that's frankly
changing all of our worlds and not in a
good way
and what i'm most focused on is africa
and needing to get them the tools the
reason that they don't show any covet is
not because they don't have it it's
because they're not tracking it
so my takeaway for you today is if you
have the opportunity to download a
coveted tracing app to use in your
locale
and california is about to have that
opportunity use it
and if you don't have an app go to covet
green and try to
get your local public health initiative
interested in that
thank you
thank you denise and uh what is
the california app gonna be called
you know it's being tested right now i
was at ucsf this morning and all the
nurses were using it and
i think it's called uh i think it's
called cover california but i'm
i think they're also still working on
that the name of it but it's been made
by google and apple
and um it's not as fancy as our app it's
much more single use
but for the purposes of knowing who
you've talked to if you fall ill
it's the way to go and it is written
with the same privacy
ideas in mind so all right
and so well thank you again yeah
check your apple store your google store
it will show up very shortly here
okay well thank you again denise for
both the work you do and for being here
today
thanks for the opportunity
all right our next speaker is
going to talk about why we want to keep
the oceans around and
more importantly the fish within them
all right thank you very much lewis take
it away
hi um i'm louis metzger and i really
thank you for the opportunity tonight
i'm going to talk about
how our future drugs will come from the
oceans and hopefully make for you
a selfish case for protecting ocean
[Music]
biodiversity
so this biodiversity is threatened by
everything from coral bleaching
to plastic accumulation to the mining of
seabed
metal nodules to things like the oil
spill that recently happened in
mauritius
evolved chemistry in the oceans and
elsewhere is one of humanity's greatest
assets
whether it be sponges that make
potentially anti-cancer compounds
or enzymes that have evolved to do green
chemistry
so nature's chemistry is encoded by dna
so
organisms via their dna rna and proteins
encode chemistry and this chemistry
evolves with the organism and ocean
organisms
encode their own chemistry fewer than 90
of ocean species have even been
identified and far fewer of that have
been carefully characterized
so what sort of drugs might lurk in the
deep and what sorts of molecules might
might we lose if we lose species
diversity
a good example would be compounds from
cone snail venom here a cone snail is
stunning a fish
as it envelops it with its stomach this
venom has evolved
over deep time in cone snails
and one of these venom components has
been used to make a non-opioid pain drug
called zucconetide and if you look at
the three-dimensional rendering on the
far right of the slide
you'll see that this is a very shapely
molecule more on that later
halichondrine b this elaborate molecule
isolated from a sponge
was used to make the drug arabulen this
is a treatment for metastatic breast
cancer
it's been successful
fucoidans are molecules that have
recently been shown from brown algae
to inhibit stars cove two viral entry
into
mammalian cells in the laboratory so
this might be a starting point for
therapeutics
alginates are polymers that are found in
algae that are used traditionally in
wound dressings but they're now being
used as scaffolds to grow new cells
for regenerative medicine
sponges inspired nucleoside analogs that
were used to develop drugs
azt the first effective hiv therapy
was derived from these nucleoside
analogs as is vela cyclovir used for
herpes
nucleoside analogs from sponges also led
to the development
of cetera being and this is a drug that
was a game changer in the treatment of
certain types of leukemia
really increasing survival rates
cyclomarines are anti-infectives
discovered from an ocean bacterium in
the bahamas
and some types of them seem to kill the
bacteria that causes tuberculosis
others target a parasite causing malaria
rampamiocene was discovered in coastal
soil on easter island
originally it was anti-fungal but it's
now a very important drug for
immunosuppressant
anti-rejection drugs and it's used to
prevent organ rejection and transplant
patients
so the ocean has many gradients
temperature light nutrients salinity
gases pressure and more
and these act upon the organisms that
live there over deep time
to result in really unique chemistry
and the evolution of organisms i should
emphasize is evolution of chemistry
dna via rna via proteins encodes
chemistry
and as organisms evolve their chemistry
evolves and
the reproduction of the conditions of
this evolution is difficult
nature's chemistry is special because it
natural molecules have handedness
acetaminophen doesn't but rifampicin on
the right with the hatch marks shows
points of handedness
and this handedness leads to shapeliness
so rifampicin
is shown in red rendered in a
space-filling model
because of these points of handedness it
fits into an enzyme that is a drug
target
shown in blue and this is a feature of
natural drugs
so many of these natural compounds are
the type of compounds that a medicinal
chemist wouldn't dream of
but have evolved in nature and if we
lose species diversity we lose chemistry
that we won't rediscover
so my takeaway is the oceans contain
medicinal treasures
that evolved in deep time and under
unique conditions and once lost they may
never be rediscovered
so preserving biodiversity is really
self-preservation
thank you for your time
thank you lewis and where do you see
uh medicine you know if we lose the
ocean
well i mean it's it's an enormous source
of biodiversity certainly there is a
biodiversity on land but
we need uh every molecular handle we can
get
to discover new drugs especially for
anti-infectives
so it would be it would be very tragic
and it's hard to put a price on that
all right well thank you very much for
being here today hopefully we won't
lose the ocean or or its biodiversity
take care
all right our next speaker is an artist
visiting us from new york
take it away madeline welcome
to the 10 000 year mystery my series of
oil paintings about a marking system for
communication over a ten thousand year
time span
here's some background for the paintings
we need a marking system to warn future
generations about the long-term danger
of nuclear waste storage sites
like this one in new mexico
think of science fiction novels that
take place in the far
future when people are trying to make
sense
of our civilization's artifacts
one challenge of long-term communication
is the drift of meaning
both linguistic and symbolic
axial procession another change over
time
will be the position of stars in a 26
000 year cycle
this is a good language free way for us
to communicate about the passage of
millennia
here's an example on the left of the
stars in new mexico is seen now in the
year 2000
on the right or the stars as they will
appear there in their fourth asset
the difference shows the passage of time
over just two thousand years
i make sky map stencils by punching
guide holes then i use those to
accurately mark
star positions on the canvas
this painting is called we left
part of the warning text reads the waste
from nuclear weapons we made
the weapons are gone but the danger
endures
transferring maps on the canvas has been
a challenge
here i take the clear plastic film over
a reverse printed topographic map
i applied oil paint to the contour lines
of the map
and then flipped it over onto the canvas
making an accurate print in the
topographic map that's those blobby
rainbow lines
and the green dots will feel the centers
are the stars
the weapons are gone but the danger is
yours
we left this message here for you we
left this here for you
we left
mule deer this painting combines an
aerial view mineral map with a horizon
view sky mount
i use a technique called gridding up to
transfer the map shapes of the canvas
i numbered the squares on the map and on
the canvas
then referred to the map as i painted in
the shapes square by square
the deer's hook prints mark the star
locations
just as dear leave tracks and trails
civilizations leave tracks and trails
for the far future
i assign the false colors to the mineral
map
in such a way that it also functions as
a traditional
vertical landscape view with the deer
looking out at us
desert raving this is a map of magnetic
anomalies of the earth
some bird species use these magnetic
fields for navigation
the bumpy warning text on the left is
buried under the matte paint as you can
see on the right
giving us thanks the physical
degradation of a warning message over
time
the raven shape reminds me of a warplane
the new mexico site is for the waste for
nuclear weapons
research and production
oracle bone chinese i really want to do
some paintings with this
i've translated the nuclear waste
warning message into this 3600 year old
language
it's another way to convey linguistic
drift over time
10 000 years in the past was the dawn of
agriculture
so long-term future thinking can be
mind-boggling
but as you've just seen long-term
thinking can also be enjoyable
i'd like to thank the long nap
foundation and ignite
for giving us the forum in which to do
that thinking and i'd like to thank you
all for being
here this evening
thank you very much madeline for uh
being here and sharing your paintings it
reminds me of uh
i mean both the motion god's eye in
which uh
civilizations keep falling and they're
constantly being reminded of their
nuclear powers and uh
and the world's knowledge and also the
foundation so
thank you thank you brandy
all right and our next speaker is
kind of going to ruminate on time and
share a project he's been working on
please welcome
scott thrift
time is funny but not haha funny
peculiar like how many times in the past
six months have you thought to yourself
something like
wait where did the time go what day is
it again
nine years ago i was having some of the
same frustrations i was super busy as we
all like to say
but i was beginning to feel like i only
lived in yesterday
or in between alerts i wanted more time
to be present
you know to live in the moment even
though i had no idea how to do that
so what is time's problem i felt
uniquely qualified to figure that out
because i had become an expert in
exploring time as a video editor
speeding time up slowing time down
making time more valuable
and then i asked the question that
changed my life how can we live in the
moment
when the moment changes every second
the problem with time is that there
isn't enough of it to get to know
time better we're going to need a longer
now
instead of making time as a filmmaker i
began to develop a series of analog
timepieces that could help myself and
others enrich
our awareness of time because there is
an uncharted territory within us all
and that is your individual temporal
bandwidth
how long is your now if we only see time
as a man-made contraption
our temporal bandwidth remains thin
forging a tenuous and fragmented
experience
of life isn't this one of the gifts of
the ten thousand-year clock
besides bringing us all together here
now it stretches our collective temporal
bandwidth
to a beacon ten thousand years ahead and
that perspective is vital
because it shows us where we are now
where we are now
is that we live in the long-term effects
of short-term thinking
how do we get to the part where we live
in the long-term effects of long-term
thinking
well there has never been a better time
than right now
to find out i believe that it is
possible for us
to change the times we live in all we
have to do
is change the time we live in
so that we can say with certainty that
that was then
and this is now the present
you are looking at the trio of
timepieces collectively known as the
present
that i have created to solve the problem
of not having more time
in this life
by tuning our awareness to the perennial
cycles of the day the moon
and the year we can collectively
rediscover the original nature of time
and a longer now
the present day is inspired by the view
of time
on earth from the window of an airplane
this 24-hour numberless clock guides you
through a spacious meditation on dawn
noon
dusk and night a generous companion to
the relentless precision
of industrial time inspired by the
design challenge of modernizing the
ancient yin yang symbol
the present moon guides you through a
29.5 days
span of shadow and light that is the
lunar cycle
the full moon at the top and the empty
moon at the bottom
inspired by the breathtaking suchness of
being alive
on earth the present year spans 365 days
gradually upgrading your depth awareness
of time
by presenting a holistic point of view
on the nature of change itself
the president invites us to be the first
generation in this century
to consciously enrich our temporal
bandwidth
and turn the page on how we read the
story
of time
story of time as we know it is still
stuck in the industrial era
but hey look at where we get to go
together we have
the chance right now to co-create a new
understanding of time that guides our
thinking and behavior
into greater harmony with nature don't
worry
industrial time isn't going anywhere
it's an incredibly useful tool
to help us be on time we don't want to
lose that
but we also don't want to focus so
closely on it that we never learn what
it's like
to be in time you see
me and thousands of other people in 42
countries
have been living with the present for
many years now and we know
that it does what we hoped it would do
the present
gives time space for a longer now
advancing our ability to read time while
expanding our temporal bandwidth to make
room for the big ideas
and the long-term solutions to all of
the current problems
that we've invented with short-term
thinking
as long as we rely solely on
short-term devices to tell the story of
time
we banish ourselves from the subtleties
of the natural world
and unconsciously limit the boundaries
of the human experience
with the present it no longer has to be
that way
thank you very much scott and when are
they going to ship
excuse me um thank you very much scott
my pleasure thank you
our next speaker was instrumental in
designing
the 10 000 year clock please welcome
stuart dixon thank you brady
can you hear me uh these are my
institutional affiliations you can
contact me at
s dixon at wolfram.com or s dixon
at mum.edu i'm going to tell you on
semi autobiographical story about how i
helped danny hillis create the equation
of time
cam for the clock of the long now in
1996 i was working on the dinosaur
production
about across the street from where denny
was a
disney corporate fellow at imagineering
uh he was designing the clock around
this time just getting started he had
seen my
illustrations in the second edition of
the mathematica book
and so he said that i was the only one
he could think of
who could make a machine part from a
mathematical equation
so the problem of keeping accurate time
for ten thousand years
uh one idea is a solar synchronizer the
problem is the solar synchronizers sees
sundial time which needs a calendrical
calculation
to convert to like atomic clock time
so uh the analemma is the position of
the sun in the sky
ever at the same time of day for a year
and
uh it's because the earth axis is tilted
and it gets even worse because
uh the equation of time morphs over
uh the period of 26 000 years
uh the with the precession of the
equinoxes
so uh danny gave me a uh mathematica
notebook with the equation of time in it
oh yeah uh the right right hand uh
side of this slide is an analemma
sundial that that
has the conversion it's the offset
between
local solar time and absolute time
you can interact with the equation of
time cam in the wolfram demonstrations
project and that really brings it
brings it home a lot better than than
just still pictures here
but here here are some still frames from
the the equation of time
demo you can see how the equation of
time morphs
over uh this is an expanse of 12 000
years that
that's uh cast onto the cam for the
clock
so how do we turn this into a physical
thing in 19 you know
1996 we use stereolithography or
laminated object manufacturing
computer-aided manufacturing applied to
a mathematical equation so
this is this is the 1989 first
advertisement for mathematica and
it's uh executable code that looks like
mathematics from an academic text and
here's
uh the um
computer-aided manufacturing part is is
making a
displaced surface with an edge on it
that can enclose material
because mathematically thin uh
surfaces can't be physically built and
so i came up with a data structure to do
this it associates
faces with edges and edges with faces
so you can do the mesh displacement you
can get uh consistent normals
and do the mesh displacement uh i i
wrote a paper in 1990 that was never
published but andrew glassner
published uh winged edge models in
graphics gyms
2 the next year so it got published
um here is some mathematica code for
the iconic collabo manifold
and the right hand side of the slide is
the uh
the traditional form of the same thing
as you would see a typeset in
mathml or something like that and so
here's the uh
the mathematical graphic of the
columbial manifold along with a
stereolithograph
of the columbial manifold you know
uh natural mathematics compiled into a
3d surface
the equation of time mathematics you can
download from the wolfram
demonstrations project and it really
doesn't look
much better in the calendrical
calculations book than it looks right
here
and so uh what i did in 1996 was uh
some fairly fairly crude computer-aided
manufacturing to turn it into an stl
file
and then danny did the casting uh uh to
turn it into a
uh machine part for the first prototype
and
and it's uh it's on display at the royal
observatory in greenwich england
so it's a an iconic object in its own
right
now and here's just another plug for my
employer
stephen wolfram is doing fundamental
physics again
and i think it's really cool and it's an
open project any anybody can
anybody can join and contribute to the
uh
to finding the fundamental theorem of
physics and computation
and thanks to the long dal foundation
and brady
for uh allowing me to be here
it was my pleasure and uh thank you for
sharing your illustrious career what are
you working on now
uh i i'm in charge of the back end data
feeds for wolfram alpha
and i'm doing i'm doing uh geometry
sculpture for
the larry spring museum of common sense
physics in fort bragg
wow well thank you for being here today
and uh look forward to seeing you at our
next one
thank you
take it away
this is a story about the end of reality
at the end of the world
the end of the idea of one consensus
world diving in let's nod to alan watts
who once said
there's no sense in clinging to the
rocks that are falling with you
fictions make us human and always have
starting forty thousand years ago with
the lyon mensch sculpture a lion-headed
man
carved from mammoth bone we've lived in
our imaginations
reality only exists in contrast with and
has always required the unreal
in the last few hundred years we've
moved from trust and hearsay in
recordings
as photography and phonography matured
and became admissible as court evidence
allowing us to get strangely lazy about
what it is we consider
authentic philosopher regina rini of
york university calls this
the epistemic backstop it's part of what
has allowed us to scale
social coordination from local networks
to a global economy
but it's a prosthetic that has eroded
other vital capabilities
over the last few years thanks to nvidia
adobe google
openai and others we've seen an
explosive evolution of machine learning
tools
that produce real seeming but fraudulent
synthetic media
by now most people have seen buzzfeed's
jordan peel barack obama deep fake
or the countless mark zuckerberg and
vladimir putin deep fakes
and it's clear how easily these could be
deployed
and will be deployed as political
weapons
but there are subtler issues with apps
like zhao and reface
which let you put your own face into
movies and music videos
democratizing this for masquerade but
opening an attack vector for identity
theft
synthetic video is concerning but vocal
forgery may be even more worrisome
because fewer people are aware of how
sophisticated it has gotten
in my 2017 sci-fi short story an oral
history of the end of reality
i imagined how you may one soon one day
soon risk having your voice
stolen simply by answering the phone
the escalating arms race between forgery
and forensics is really just a
continuation of the forces
that drove humankind to pioneer modern
science in the first place
after all the more perspectives in
agreement the better
there is a silver lining here in that
this undercuts our arrogance
bringing scientific rigor home to roost
and forcing us to ask
sophisticated questions about our
confidence in so-called facts
new conceptions of reality will be far
more nuanced and multi-dimensional than
those of the present day
but for now the threats are apocalyptic
and new literacy is desperately needed
only a few projects such as michael
morgenstern's i dared my best friend to
ruin my life
have emerged to help people understand
how to navigate these vertiginous new
social landscapes
but lying is nothing new and people have
always abused trust
it's already the case that world powers
act as if reality is what you make it
just look at the explosion of fake news
our conceit that recordings are more
trustworthy than hearsay is a huge
exploit in the code of society
collective action problems require a
narrative cohesion
to weave the social fabric of our future
and the manufacture of convincing
counterfeits is a kind of black magic
by all accounts it's fair to say that
information warfare
is magical warfare which means the end
of the modern hubris of naive realism
and requires us to reclaim some aspects
of pre-modernity
living in the future may ultimately feel
more like living in a world of an
indigenous cosmology in which the
imaginal
is on equal ontological footing with the
physical world
which brings us to the pragmatism of
fiction most of the brain doesn't
differentiate between the real and the
unreal which is why fiction is so
powerful
why first theater and now cinema have
held such power over us
visualization exercises are a mainstay
of wisdom traditions worldwide
an ancient tool to develop and
internalize our highest potentials
the modern world is simply waking up to
the instrumental nature of fictions
as a force for shaping collective
behavior for instance
artist stephanie lepp's project deep
reckonings makes explicit deep fakes
of powerful abusers taking
responsibility for their actions
helping us imagine what it would look
like for them to assume accountability
and maybe even moral leadership other
projects like dali lives
bring history back to life mit's deep
empathy
motivates human rights action by showing
us ruined versions of privileged cities
putting the affluent in the shoes of
those suffering from global catastrophe
deep fakes can help us imagine better
versions of ourselves
much like the established use of mirrors
in physical therapy to trick the brain
into imagining wounded body parts as
whole
the fact is we have always lived in our
imagination
and reality is the most pernicious and
dangerous fiction of them all
deep fakes may make it harder for us to
agree on which myths we should act on
but the real world was always a mirage
and we only stand to gain
by leaving it behind thank you
thank you michael i mean this reminds me
of uh
uh lewis clark quote any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
magic
indeed on how the future is
indistinguishable from magic you can
find it on my medium account
all right and what which of these
technologies scares you the most
uh the oral and oral history of the end
of reality was entirely
about vocal synthesis uh at first and
then trailing into haptics
i think haptics uh is actually the kind
of the scariest thing if you look at the
work that was
uh patented recently by disney
imagineering
the idea of being able to reproduce
someone's touch
with like sophisticated robotics i think
is is really
the one that creeps me out the most
yeah that reminds me of a scene from uh
a jack ryan book cardinal the kremlin
when the person is trapped in an
immersion tank
and then tortured over 30 hours if
haptics were uh
were useful for that that'd be pretty
nightmarish
well on that on that pleasant note thank
you very much for being with us today
and now i'm going to welcome on uh the
executive director of the long now
xander rose hey hey xander
this was so fantastic brady thank you
and your crew i know what a monumental
effort is to
to wrestle all the cats into the the
right format so this was
this was really fantastic well
thanks for uh teaming up with us super
fun and the caps were great
yeah i know i mean there's so many
themes you know the concrete you know
actually one of the great uh
the people who studies that the
multi-thousand-year-old concrete from
rome is right here in the bay area and
at uc berkeley who we've worked with on
the clock clock project
um those those kind of vesuvian
concretes were
um were figured out for some of the
nuclear waste repositories so that kind
of has good echoes to
that project but also just to be able to
see old friends like scott thrift and
denise and
stuart and uh catherine even um it's
been a long time since being able to see
you all in person so
and then also seeing some new members
and our goal is to make this an annual
tradition
of uh bringing our members uh more
forward and so that we can hear some of
these great stories so
um we did it the first time at the uh at
the first
member um gathering a few years ago
but you organized so um i'm i'm loving
this as a
as a tradition that we keep doing so
hopefully other members are listening
and can prepare their talks for next
year
awesome yeah we'll be here and thank you
audra
and uh if anyone wants to speak at
ignite sf we'll be doing some more
virtual ones
and thank you very much xander thank you
thank you guys